-Republicans are rushing
to confirm
the Supreme Court nominee
of a president
who is in so much legal jeopardy
even his own lawyers
have warned him
he could go to jail.
For more on this,
it's time for A Closer look.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's just step back for
a moment and consider that fact
that Trump is trying
to appoint someone
to a lifetime seat
on the Supreme Court
while simultaneously
being implicated
in a truly staggering number
of criminal cases
and corruption scandals.
That's like Bonnie
getting arrested and saying,
"You know who's make
a great judge?
Clyde."
[ Laughter ]
Just to review,
here's what we already know
about the various crimes
and corruption scandals
swirling around
the president --
his campaign chairman
was convicted
on eight counts
of tax and bank fraud,
his deputy campaign chairman
admitted to embezzlement
and money laundering,
his personal lawyer admitted
he conspired with the president
to break federal election laws
to pay hush money
to cover up an affair,
his national security adviser
plead guilty
to lying to the FBI about his
contacts with the Russians,
his foreign policy adviser
also plead guilty
to lying to the FBI about
his contacts with the Russians,
his first
congressional backer
was indicted
for insider trading,
his second congressional backer
was indicted
for wire fraud
and campaign-finance violations,
a Republican lobbyist
just plead guilty
to steering illegal funds
from a pro-Russian oligarchy
to Trump's inauguration,
and Steven Miller
has been sleeping rent-free
in the White House attic.
[ Laughter ]
Now...
[ Applause, laughter ]
...Trump's already --
already expressed support
for a few of those guys.
And now, he's backing
two more alleged criminals --
GOP congressmen Chris Collins
and Ducan Hunter.
On Monday, Trump slammed
Attorney General Jeff Sessions
for allowing prosecutors
to bring cases against them.
openly admitting that
those cases were hurting
Republicans' chances
in the midterm elections.
-The president writes, quote,
"Two long-running, Obama era,
investigations of two very
popular Republican congressmen
were brought to a
well-publicized charge,
just ahead of
the midterms,
by the Jeff Sessions
Justice Department.
Two easy wins
now in doubt
because there is
not enough time.
Good job, Jeff."
"The Democrats -- none of whom
voted for Jeff Sessions --
must love him now."
-First of all,
no one loves Jeff Sessions.
[ Laughter ]
He looks like
a haunted doll
that moves whenever
you look away.
"I could have sworn I put my
Little Sessions of that chair.
Oh, my God,
he's behind me!"
[ Laughter ]
Second --
think about that.
Trump just openly admitted
on Twitter
that he wants
the Justice Department --
which is supposed
to be independent --
to cover up crimes
by Republicans
in order to help them
win elections.
Not only is Trump corrupt,
but he's so obvious about it.
He's like a guy who would try to
pick your pocket from the front.
[ As Trump ] "Whoops.
I've bumped into you by
accident.
now, just give me a second,
and I'll be on my way.
Come on, wallet.
where are you, wallet."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
In fact, today, we got
some explosive new details
about just how much
legal jeopardy
Trump's own lawyers
think he might be in.
Excerpts from famed journalist
Bob Woodward's forthcoming book
about the Trump White House
began to leak out,
including one conversation
where Trump's lawyer,
John Dowd, warned Trump
that if he testified
to the Russia probe,
he might go to jail.
"Dowd was convinced that Trump
would commit perjury
if he talked to
Special Counsel Robert Mueller.
But Trump,
concerned about the optics
of a president
refusing to testify,
and convinced that he could
handle Mueller's questions,
had, by then,
decided otherwise.
Trump told Dowd,
'I'll be a real good witness.'
Dowd replied,
'You are not a good witness.'"
[ Laughter ]
In fact, the Mueller inquiry
apparently looms
over the White House every day,
to the point where
even foreign leaders
ask Trump about it.
According to
the Washington Post,
"Hovering over the White House
was Mueller's inquiry,
which deeply embarrassed
the president.
Woodward describes Trump calling
his Egyptian counterpart
to secure the release
of an imprisoned charity worker,
and President
Abdel Fatah al-Sissi saying,
'Donald, I'm worried about
this investigation.
Are you going to be around?'
Trump relayed
the conversation to Dowd,
and said it was
'like a kick in the nuts.'"
In fairness, every day
working in your White House
is like a kick in the nuts.
Why do you think Rudy Guiliani
always looks like this?
[ Laughter ]
That's...
[ Applause ]
That's the face of a guy
who lost a bet
and has to stand in front of
a tennis-ball machine
without a racket.
[ Laughter ]
Apparently, Trump knew
this book would be explosive,
because last month he called
Woodward to talk about it.
Woodward recorded the call,
and as he explained to Trump
what the book would be about,
you can hear it
slowly dawn on Trump that it
could be very damaging for him.
-It's also a difficult time,
where the political system,
and you and my business...
-Yeah.
-...is being tested.
-And I take it very seriously.
I've done books
on eight presidents,
going back
from Nixon to Obama.
-Right.
-And I learned something
about reporting, frankly,
Mr. President.
-Good.
-I've got to go talk to people,
and see them
outside of the White House,
and outside
of their offices.
And I've gained a lot
of insight and documentation.
And it's -- you know,
it's a tough look
at the world, and your
administration, and you.
-Right. Well,
I assume that means
it's gonna be
a negative book.
-Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
He's like a guy
who doesn't understand
why he's being dumped.
"I'm breaking up with you
because you're dumb, annoying,
selfish, ugly,
and I don't like you,
and I'm not attracted to you
in any way."
[ As Trump ] "So, it sounds like
you're on the fence
about going to prom with me."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] So, Trump
is harassing and threatening
the Justice Department,
and even his own lawyers
have warned him
he might go to jail,
which is why it's absurd
to let him appoint anyone
to a permanent seat
on the Supreme Court,
let alone a life-long
partisan Republican
like Brett Kavanaugh.
And yet,
not only are Republicans
rushing forward
within Kavanaugh's nomination,
they're doing it with an
unprecedented level of secrecy.
"The Trump White House,
citing executive privilege,
is withholding
from the Senate
more than 100,000
pages of records
from Kavanaugh's time
as a lawyer
in the Bush
administration."
Republicans are trying to hide
as much about Kavanaugh's record
as they can because they know
it would be damning.
So, what do they want you to
know about Kavanaugh instead?
they want you to know that
he's just like
your next-door neighbor.
-This is a guy
who coaches basketball,
who does all kinds
of food pantries.
He's like
your next-door neighbor.
-And then,
he talked about his daughter.
And then, he talked about CYO
and food pantries.
And I said, "You know what?
This is the guy next door."
-Just a really nice guy.
Just a decent person,
a person of integrity.
You have to see
his eyes light up
when he talks
about his daughters,
coaching their
basketball team.
-One friend called him,
"A regular, old carpool dad."
I think we all know
what that is.
It's the dad who drives
the kids to school.
-[ Sarcastically ]
Oh, is that what it is?
[ Laughter ]
The two words
with their exact definitions?
"He's like
a peanut-butter sandwich.
We all know
what that is.
It's a sandwich
with peanut butter on it."
[ Laughter ]
And I'm sorry
you think he's qualified
to be a Supreme Court justice
because he's a carpool dad.
Anyone can drive a car.
Ruth Bader Ginsburg
pulled one
when she wore -- when she won
World's Strongest Judge.
[ Laughter ]
Now, today,
Democrats tried
to do everything they could
to delay the hearing
until all of Kavanaugh's
records were released.
And the chairman
of the committee --
Iowa senator
Chuck Grassley --
did everything he could
to ignore them.
For example,
when several Democratic senators
tried to interrupt
Grassley's opening statement
to register their objections,
he just shouted over them.
-We cannot possibly
move forward, Mr. Chairman --
-I extend a very warm welcome...
-We have not been given...
-...to Judge Kavanaugh...
-...an opportunity
to have a meaningful hearing...
-...to his wife, Ashley...
-...on this nominee.
-...their two daughters...
-Mr. Chairman...
-...their extended family...
-...I agree with my colleague...
-...and friends.
-...Senator Harris.
Mr. Chairman...
[ Indistinct talking,
interrupting ]
-You know you're not
in a good place
when you have to scream your
banal compliments at the
witness.
[ Yelling ] "I want to
extend a very warm welcome
to your wife
and you two daughters!
I know that you are
a carpool dad --
which is a dad
who carpools!"
[ Scattered applause, laughter ]
[ Applause ]
[ Normal voice ]
Then...
when Senator Corey Booker
interrupted Grassley
to express his frustration
with the process,
Grassley tried
a new tactic --
ignoring Booker
and softly tapping his gavel.
-This committee, sir,
[ Gavel gently tapping ]
is a violation
of even the values
I've heard you talk about
time and time again,
The ideals that
we should have.
What is the rush?
What are we
trying to hide
by not having
the documents out front?
What is with the rush?
[ Gavel gently tapping ]
What are we hiding
by not letting
those documents
come out?
You've called for documents.
[ Gavel Gently tapping ]
You yourself --
limited documents.
We thought there
should be more.
We have not
received the documents
that you have even called for.
[ Gavel gently tapping ]
-Oh, my God. When Chuck Grassley
knocks on someone's door,
they probably don't even
know he's there.
[ Laughter ]
"Chuck!
how long have you been here?"
[ As Grassley ]
"Five hours."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
When he tries to kill a fly,
it probably
takes him forever.
[ Laughter ]
Is he calling for order
or trying to keep track
of his pulse?
[ Laughter ]
Hey...
Hey. Republicans say
we don't need to see
all of Kavanaugh's
records to confirm him
to the Supreme Court.
And at least
they've been consistent.
I'm sure there isn't
video of Grassley
from just a few years ago
saying the exact opposite
about President Obama's nominee
for the court, Elena Kagan.
-The Senate needs enough time
to adequately review
the nominee's record.
In order for the Senate
to fulfill
its constitutional
responsibility
of advice and consent,
we must get all of her documents
from the Clinton Library
and have enough time
to analyze them,
so that we can determine whether
she should be a justice.
-Wow. The only thing
missing from that clip
was Grassley slowly banging
his gavel at himself.
-We must get
all of her documents
from the Clinton Library
[ Gavel gently bangs ]
and have enough time
to analyze them
so that we can determine whether
she should be a justice.
[ Gavel gently bangs ]
-Republicans are
rushing to confirm
the Supreme Court nominee
of a president
under criminal investigation
who's trying to subvert
the justice system
to his own political ends
so they can
roll back voting rights,
reproductive rights,
and workers' rights,
and solidify their
grip on power.
And their only argument
is that he's a...
-"..carpool dad."
-This has been
A Closer Look.
[ Applause ]